[Music]
when I said last week that I was part of
the gig economy because I was a
freelancer people rightly laughed at me
in public look forward to seeing her
cycling through Thornton Heath with a
delivery box of lukewarm curry strapped
to her back said a Gillian on Twitter
you're right I couldn't imagine the
horror Gillian the Internet is a
wonderful thing but it's also helped to
bring back the primitive brutal
conditions of the Liverpool docks in the
early part of the last century or even
the 18th century where workers at idle
and unpaid waiting for peace work to
come their way
jobs used to mean holiday entitlement
sick pay maternity leave voluntary
overtime and a pay packet at the end of
the month now millions on 0as contracts
or working in the gig economy have no
protections or rights or security or
guarantees at all so I'm with Archbishop
Justin Welby who described this as an
oppression of workers and the
incarnation of an ancient evil we
abolished the slave trade donkey's years
ago why are we allowing this
exploitation of the lowest-paid to take
root now I'm innovating in principle you
have to be right don't you in principle
people should get holiday pay people
should get sick pay people should get
all the advantages that come with
full-time jobs if they're doing casual
jobs but of course some people quite
like casual jobs and that's why I don't
quite know I mean you know McDonald's
off most of their stuff what did they
think about casual jobs that so they
quite like them a lot of people I like
doing casual jobs whether it's for tax
relations whether it's cash I have no
idea but then in principle you've got to
be right I mean we input and I think
well be it's worth looking at what will
be six I think he was he was right there
are some who view that kind of
impression of the employed as a virtue
the gay economy zero hours contract
is nothing new it is simply the
reincarnation of an ancient evil there
is a difference though isn't there
between the casual someone who does hilt
couple of nights a week up the pub
working on the pub and gets some money
and people who are doing proper jobs and
sometimes they're doing that as an
additional job to the other one God yeah
I think I think we have to accept that
the popular concept of a nine-to-five
job people lots of people don't want
that anymore and you know and and I hear
all the arguments about instability and
insecurity of the gig economy but no job
is is safe or secure anymore none of us
are but I think I think what we've got
to be careful I think anyone who is
doing a job the same job for for you
know five days in a week and he should
get thing but the problem is a lot of
people like this and if if if you start
bringing in benefits and expenses and
holiday pay bosses of those companies I
have gonna have to take a greater
control of their gig workers and many of
them don't want that they value the
control of their time and that we know
take uber drivers most duper drivers
it's not their main job they had it they
have a primary job which doesn't they
don't make enough money but they they
they go and drive a car you do these apt
jobs because it brings them a few extra
Bob and I think we just got to accept
nine-to-five doesn't it I read one
interesting stat that said today's 15
year olds will probably have five
totally different careers in their
lifetime and that's all to do with this
way of working now you hang on a minute
because there will be people watching
this screen this program absolutely
screaming because yes you're absolutely
right you too that if you chew for some
people okay Joyce but I'm sorry but
there are so many companies out there
and I'm taking the piss out of their
work and they are doing it for one
reason and one reason it's only they are
doing it to increase their profits and
they're doing it to reduce their
liabilities now I have a problem with
this you know I know lots and lots of
people and I do think it's a form of
exploitation actually you know I
remember one of you choose to if you
choose allowing people the choice if you
choose that brilliant if you better
fight let me yeah
I've had to fight to be workers rather
than self-employment but what am i one
of my brothers he used to work for a
company and I am allowed to name them
OCS retail he used to do stocktaking
and they used to pick him up not just my
brother they used to pick up a van load
of these kids these these land saw or
ladies as well they used to drive them
for hours and hours and hours on end and
then they these workers or whatever the
companies to call them used to do manual
stop taking in retailers in in the
middle of the night Ali hours of the
morning and then that be driven hours
and hours and hours back home and they
would only prepared you know very very
low wages for the hours and when they
would didn't know when they were doing
it as well Nick what I want to say
couple of things I've actually been
going through a scrapbook of pictures of
you so I've got a response to Jillian in
just a moment you mentioned OCS I should
tell you we have approached OCS and
they've declined to offer any comments
so we just need to get that out there
but it's not fair what Jillian said
about you you are a gig worker this
picture of you as a child to prove it to
me sweet yes you as a chimney-sweep you
know what I think there's elements of
what everybody said is right yeah the
workplace is going undergoing the most
extraordinary revolution I look at my
sons and many of their former colleagues
they set up businesses in coffee shops
they don't they don't want to do no they
don't want they don't wanna have a boss
they're their own boss and part of that
is and I think it's a bit respectfully
as I saw Michels was a bit too we don't
want face was some people says but it's
a bit too simplistic and I don't quite
know how you'd do it otherwise well I
think there are ways forward and we
don't know we don't wait okay hold on to
your hat then I think the problem with
the labor market is it was it's become
very polarized we've got high paid
professionals on the point and on
employment contract and we've got the
zero as gig economy at the bottom and
and 25 percent of those surveyed by
YouGov the other day are on working for
less than 7 pounds 50 an hour okay there
is a way forward which is do they have
higher productivity than we do and they
have higher we have had wage stagnation
as a result of zeros contract and they
give that is so loving though we have a
very tight labor market
with the new pope ideas for immigration
after it's going to be even tighter if
we're going to really cut down in there
you know we have to have a higher skills
I have paid higher trim if you're gonna
give workers benefits and holiday pay it
means more status approach to employment
because the government will have to
introduce laws that say employers cannot
have X number employers on zero hours
contract with no benefits whatsoever
employers will then have more control
over their employees because they're
giving them better packages it's going
to be more controlled more like France
and Germany but higher paid and higher
I remember when independence first came
in there were people who were working
for those who we're not getting any
holiday pie or anything else everyone
said this would be terrible we couldn't
afford it though so well actually it was
implemented you had to do it and
actually they were 750 an hour if you're
working five days a week in the same
company and and on a zero hours contract
and you're not getting any but yes you
should get benefits but if you're
working for hours here three hours there
on whatever days you choose well then
you know you shouldn't have those
benefits yes sorry you've heard my
manifesto where we've got to hit on
McDonald's labor all workers will have
equal trade union rights from day one
whether they're part-time full-time
temporary or permanent zero hours
contracts will be banned so that every
worker gets a guaranteed numbers of
hours each week what I was trying to do
it's trying to tackle the fact that high
tech has led to you know new
technologies led to very old working
practices as you what say nothing he's
an opposition he doesn't have to do it
now Michelle's point is valid there are
supermarkets there are DIY stores there
also and there are others that are
exploiting these people you don't know
how much work you're gonna get you're
trying to raise a family that's the
point is a business surely you've got a
responsibility if I was running like I
don't know a major supermarket I would
want a hat of a responsibility of
looking at the employee
practices of my supply chain so it's one
thing just being the supermarket saying
this is what I do with my employee is or
whatever you want to call them but I
would think that if you've got for
example example I give let your
outsourcing stop taking to large
organizations surely is a responsible
supermarket or retailer you'd want to
make sure that they are treating their
employees workers self-employed
contractors whatever you want to call
them fairly and often they are not in
and I have the time if you're running a
supermarket it's just no it's not
unrealistic you have significant human
resource environments and departments it
is not unrealistic to make the decision
to invest the time to understand the
human resource practices of your supply
chain it's a great idea okay you're
watching the page on Sky News up next
[Music]
see a penny pick it up all day long
you'll have good luck
[Music]